new New York Times editorial board
member sarahx Sean keeps her job despite
racist tweets Jim Acosta loves that dude
some Jim Acosta and president Trump
argues with Ivanka over the media I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh man we have a fun show for you today
so many things to talk about but first I
need to remind you that you need to
stock up on some precious metals again
the reality of the world suggests that
inflation is a possibility the national
debt is a serious problem that's money
that we owe other countries it's money
that we are going to have to raise
through bonds or through taxes that
could create inflation on the other end
if your entire life savings is tied to
the US dollar you have to ask yourself
what is your plan from hyperinflation if
the stilts fall out from under the
economy with higher wages there's an
increase in minimum wage across the
country too that could lead to price
inflation import prices are going to
skyrocket with trade wars raw material
prices are increasing with tariffs
rising housing prices all of this could
lead the government to actually start
printing more money which could lead to
a certain level of inflation meaning
that your savings are worth less well
this is why you ought to use some of
your money to buy gold right my savings
plan is diversified in yours should be
to the company that I trust with
precious metals purchases Birch gold
group and right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
it's perfect for people who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from any future geopolitical
uncertainty look back historically when
the bottom falls out of everything gold
tends to safeguard savings Birch gold
group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact Birch gold group right
now to request a free information kit on
precious metals this comprehensive 16
page kit reveals how gold and silver can
protect your savings it can legally move
your IRA or 401k out of risky stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA to
get that no-cost no-obligation kit just
go to birchgold.com slash pen that's
birchgold.com slash Ben there's a reason
that I trust the folks over at Birch
gold to do my precious metals investing
you should trust them as well make sure
you ask all your questions then once you
have your answers head over there get
that free information kit when you go to
birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben go check it out
right now
okay so meanwhile let's talk a little
bit about the New York Times so the New
York Times about a year ago tried to
hire a tech reporter this tech reporter
turned out was friends with some rather
unsavory people on the Internet and
people dug up her old tweets and then
the New York Times fired this person the
New York Times however has not fired a
woman named Sarah Shum Sarah Zhang is
their new tech person on the New York
Times editorial board and
has some pretty bad tweets now as a
person who's been targeted for old
tweets it is my opinion that old tweets
should not end your career as a general
rule unless they are a revelation to the
person who hired you so for example if I
had a bunch of tweets 10 years old and
somebody had hired me and they didn't
know about my old tweets like that been
public fodder they hadn't done their
research or something and then it came
to light then firing me would not be the
end of the world if however they knew
what they were getting when they hired
me then they should not fire me over
calls to boycott they should not fire me
just on a principled level over over
them making a bad decision like the
fault of the New York Times here is the
fault of the New York Times it's not
Sarah Zhang's fault she tweeted this
stuff in the past four years and the New
York Times just didn't do its research
or if they did do their research they
obviously didn't care that's it so
that's a little bit different from for
example the Roseanne Barr situation
where ABC fully knew that Roseanne Barr
was kind of a crazy person but she then
tweeted something new and that new thing
was something that it's new information
Disney didn't have it when they decide
to hire Rosanna maybe she didn't have
one they decided to hire Roseanne and so
that sort of changes the equation well
Sarah's young all this stuff has been
known okay and here's some of the stuff
that she tweeted and I'll explain why
this matter she tweeted oh man it's kind
of sick how much joy I get out of being
cruel to old white men and she also
tweeted this dumbass effing white people
marking up the internet with their
opinions like dogs pissing on fire
hydrants right they she's just a
delightful delightful person and it's
not just restricted to that there's some
old tweets that are now surfacing about
cops where she tweeted stuff like oh boy
I sure would fight the cops with my guns
I wonder why black people haven't
thought of doing that huh and let me
know when a cop gets killed by a rock or
a Molotov cocktail or a stray shard of
glass from a precious precious window
and says when homeless people can beat
cops senseless and suffer nary a
repercussion then let's talk about
accountability going both ways so she's
an execrable human I mean she she seems
like a bad person these are not good
tweets but the New York Times knew all
this when they hired her so the New York
Times came out and they defended her
which tells you something about the New
York Times I think it is good by the way
that employers are not jumping to firing
people based on social media mobbing
this lady is a bad lady but I don't
think that it is a good thing as a
general rule for employers to start
firing people based on the social media
mob getting angry right we've seen this
from the left too many times to think
that it's any better when it comes from
the right it's just not a good idea to
have blowback
on Twitter Drive whether somebody can
hold a job or not as a general rule hey
but the New York Times released a
statement and their statement is more
telling about the New York Times than
anything else because as I say a year
ago the New York Times fired somebody
for doing exactly what seryeong did
except that she was perceived to be on
the right
Sara Jang is perceived to be on the left
so she gets to keep her job here is what
the New York Times said they said we
hired Sara Zhang because of the
exceptional work she's done covering the
internet and technology at a range of
respected publications her journalism
and the fact that she is a young asian
woman have made her subject of frequent
online harassment for a period of time
she responded to that harassment by
imitating the rhetoric of her accusers
okay this is legitimately the worst
excuse I have ever heard for why you
would treat wasted racist stuff that's
really really people were treating
racist stuff at me
so in imitation of them I decided to
tweet racist stuff back at them yeah
that that's good good excuse
bought well done guys and then the New
York Times says she now sees that this
approach only served to feed the vitriol
that we too often see on social media
she regrets it and The Times does not
condone it
we had candid conversations with Sarah
as part of our thorough vetting process
which included a review of her social
media history she understands that this
type of rhetoric is not acceptable at
the times and we are confident she will
be an important voice for the editorial
board moving forward so several things
can be true here once one I don't think
the New York Times should fire this lady
they broke it they bought it
hey they bought it they knew what she
was when they hired her they should bear
the consequences if you choose not to
subscribe to the New York Times you have
every right to do that and they should
bear the consequences of their own
decision making - does the New York
Times have a double standard you bet
your ass they have a double standard you
bet your life they have a double
standard there is no question the New
York Times has an insane double standard
not only does the New York Times have an
insane double standard
Sarah Zhong has an insane double
standard because it turns out Sarah Jean
loves at social media mobbing she's been
part of it Tim hunt you'll recall is a
former honorary professor with the
University College London School of Life
and Medical Sciences he's a Nobel Prize
winner in Physiology and medicine as
well as recipients of the Royal medal he
made a joke one time in a speech about
how young women and young mention work
in laboratories together because they
tend to fall in love how do you know
this was a joke because he was
specifically referencing the fact that
he married his lab assistants right he
met he who is a scientist in her own
right people took this as well he's
saying women shouldn't be in the
laboratory which is weird since his wife
is actually a very highfalutin
scientists in her own right he was
basically mobbed out of a job he had to
resign his job he was punished by all of
the academies of which he was a part and
here's what Sarah Jean Tong tweeted at
the time Tim hunt sad Tim hunt too sad
to do science Twitter criticized him and
he just start crying she's really a
delight and then there was John's
reaction to the firing of Benny Johnson
who now works over at the Daily Caller a
long time ago Benny was caught up in a
sort of plagiarism accusation and Sarah
Jang tweeted up lots of talented people
never make mistakes and they still have
trouble finding jobs F Benny Johnson's
Redemption well I mean I think that we
could probably apply that same logic to
Sarah Zhang and then she said this about
Justine Sacco remember Justine Sacco
does the woman PR executive who was on a
plane and she was traveling to Africa
and she tweeted something about getting
AIDS and by the time she lands it her
life had basically been destroyed she'd
tweeted this bad joke about AIDS and
suddenly she was out of a job no one
would hire her she had been made a
pariah all across the media I mean it
was is really insane people were we're
tweeting has justine landed yet and this
became a top trending twitter hashtag
because virtue signaling on twitter is
extraordinarily strong here's what Sarah
Jean tweeted about that what I'm getting
at is that what happened to Sacco was
not that bad and white America's
obsession with her is deeply telling so
that wasn't bad either it turns out that
when Barry Weiss a New York Times
columnist was mobbed for having
suggested that the right was being
mistreated online Sara Jean was very
upset about that she says is there
anything more tedious than media
navel-gazing over outraged mobs start
paying attention to what's happening
outside her Ivy League New York City
centric circles look at how the pylons
operate in other contexts and get some
bleep perspective she did a bad tweet
she got engagement for it and then she
didn't want to engage back what exactly
was Barry Weiss's bad tweet her bad
tweet was she said immigrants get the
job done when she was talking about the
daughter of an immigrant who went to the
Olympics and ice skating that was that
that was her bad tweeked and Sarah Zhang
said she deserved everything she got the
discourse is not being harmed because of
people questioning a bad ice-skating
tweet the discourse started getting
harmed with say the online death threats
etc once you've seen enough of these you
can also see that people tweeting at
Barry Weiss's not a big deal lol Brenda
nice I mean it's over and over she's
been part of these social media mobs
urging them on cheering them so there is
a fair bit of karmic justice to Sarah
Jean now being social media mobs
now do I think again
for the 11th time in the segment do I
think that employers should start firing
people based on social media mobbing I
do not I think it's a mistake I think
employers should only fire employees if
they are feeling actual business
blowback from the decisions of those
employees made well in the employ of
those employers ok but this is not that
so I don't think Sara's wrongs should be
fired I think she should sit on the New
York Times editorial board and we should
continue to characterize the New York
Times as a terrible piece of garbage
newspaper I think that seems to me the
fairest outcome here that she should
have to work there after having
criticized the New York Times for years
by the way as being too right-wing
she should have to work there and then
we can all sit here and laugh at the New
York Times for being stupid enough to
hire somebody like Sarah Zhang by the
way I think it is worthwhile noting that
Sarah Zhang the real reason she wasn't
fired is not because the New York Times
has suddenly discovered the evils of
social media mobbing that is not why she
was not fired ok she was not fired
because the New York Times agrees with
her she was not fired because the New
York Times agrees with her take on white
America they are a bunch of white upper
crust New York elitists who believe that
anyone who is not white in the United
States is inherently under the boot of
Uncle Sam and therefore when Sarah's
young tweets racist stuff about white
people it's because white people deserve
it how do I know this because there are
people on the Left who say the sort of
stuff openly so there's an idiot named
Zack Beauchamp and I say idiot advisedly
I think it may be too kind of word for
him he's a columnist over at voxcom
which is the most Eisley of the of the
commentariat it's a hive of villainy and
scum and I say that having actual
friends who work there right like little
story ok little story after Zack
Beauchamp wrote an article two weeks ago
suggesting that Mark Duplass this
independent director we talked about on
the show he tweeted something nice about
me and then after he was social media
mobs he's a leave the nice tweet about
me and then issued a public apology for
ever having said anything nice about me
Zack Beauchamp wrote a piece for voxcom
suggesting that I completely deserved it
and Mark Duplass was exactly right
because I'm a horrible horrible human
being
so mark Duplass should have been social
media mob and he should have deleted the
tweet and all the rest of this stuff I
got letters from two different Vox
writers who would not come out publicly
and say so saying Zack Beauchamp is an
idiot and you're not a bad person
because I know you and we talk
frequently in any case Zack Beauchamp
tweets this out yesterday right here's
what he tweets out a lot of people on
the internet today confusing the
expressive way anti racist and
minorities talk
white people unquote with actual
race-based hatred for some unfathomable
reason so he looks at those tweets from
tweets that say things like and I quote
dumbass effing white people marking up
the internet with their opinions like
dogs pissing on fire hydrants and he
says that this is actually the
expressive way anti-racist and
minorities talk about white people and
this should never be confused with
actual race-based hatred it would be
unfathomable for you to actually equate
these two things like when you say
dumbass effing white people how could I
not read that as oh that's just the
expressive way that Asian people talk
which is racist you idiot
okay Zack Bowe challenge is just the
worst he's just the worst and then David
you walk him who is I guess a writer for
he's in it for the ex newer times writer
he tweets out dear white people racism
is about the powerful keeping down the
powerless no it isn't no it isn't racism
can be used by the powerful to keep down
the powerless but racism is not about
the powerful keeping down the powerless
racism is about race-based hatred that
is the actual definition we generally
are the powerful meaning we white people
white people isn't a slur oh really it's
not a slur well you see black people and
they make a giant generalization about
black people like their dumb ass effing
black people don't you say something
awful awful terrible like that and see
how that goes for you David Jakob then
he says the F word for for gay people
and the N word are slurs because they
subordinate you know as opposed to
saying dumb me dumb ass effing white
people that's not subordinating white
people in any way since your moral
equivalence is nonsense reverse racism
isn't a thing
you're right reverse racism isn't a
thing it's just called racism it's just
called racism it's not reverse racism
it's just called racism but this is an
actual perspective on the left an actual
perspective on the Left suggests that
racism from the powerful is the only
thing that matters there is no such
thing as racism in any other context
right the left tends to see things in
this Marxist universe where power
relations are the entirety of what we
should be talking about everyday
relations between the more powerful
groups and the less powerful groups and
the less powerful groups are less
powerful because those power less
powerful groups have been put upon by
the more powerful groups as I always say
the Marxist view of life is that if you
have two people in a room one person has
five bucks one person has one buck it
must be that the person with five
dollars somehow subordinated the person
with one dollar
that is not true in a free country but
this is how the left sees things so if
white people are racist then their their
racism is really just a tool of their
power but if black people are racist
that or Asian people are racist or
Mexicans are racist or Jews are racist
then this means that they are just
fighting back against the man they're
just fighting back against the man and
they are using the tools at their
disposal to fight back against this
power relationship this is how you end
up with this foolishness of
intersectionality suggesting that
certain opinions are worth more than
others based on the color of the skin of
the person who's making a particular
argument talk a little bit more about
that in just one second first let's talk
about your security so we have a sponsor
ring they're the video doorbell company
they allow you to see and speak to
anyone when they come to your door
well they've now sent us actual footage
of ring busting crooks in the act this
one is just creepy I don't actually know
if this guy is a criminal or not suffice
it to say he is not coming to the door
to live or a pizza and things get real
weird here is what that looks like hey
sorry we're in the middle of dinner can
I help you yes how are you good how are
you good see you in a while I don't know
who you are
I'm Justin I met you long time ago
[Music]
Wow listen that guy's weird and you
wouldn't want him do you want to open
the door and you see that you know right
across the screen like that that's into
the screen door that's not a good idea
and that's why you need the ring video
doorbell you will never miss a visitor
including visitors like Justin or Jason
whether you're home or away you can see
and speak to visitors on your smartphone
from anywhere even share video clips to
neighbors using the ring app we have the
ring floodlight cam at home in the
spotlight cam you can build a ring of
security around your entire property
rings products are just fantastic stop
crime before it happens help make your
neighborhood safer with ring and you can
save up to 150 bucks on a ring of
security kit at ring comm slash Bend
that's ring comm / Ben 150 bucks off
when you go to ring calm / bed and go
check it out right now use that slash
Ben so they know that we sent you okay
so final note on this tendency of the
left to be okay with racism so long as
it's not coming from white people I was
talking with a leftist friend who
happens to work with an F or mention
publication we were talking about
intersectionality and she's saying all
inter
sexuality really is his context it's
just trying to suggest that every
interaction has a context in which group
characteristics play apart and I said
well I'm not sure number one that every
interaction does have that context and
second of all if there is a context in
which for example black people suffer
more from racism than white people if
that's true I think that it if we're
talking about how much that impacts
disparities between group outcome I
think that may account for a small
percentage of the disparity between
group outcome maybe 15 20 percent but
intersectional theorists think it's 90
percent and normal Democrats think that
it's 60 percent and that's why they're
constantly railing about societal
injustice and not taking into account
that people should just not act like
jerks and this is true of Sarah's young
people on the Left look at Sarah's
realities Asian she must've been put
upon she went to Harvard Law School the
the if we're gonna talk about group
characteristics the highest-earning
group in the United States are Asian
Americans white Americans are in 76
cents on the dollar for every dollar
earned by an Asian household okay white
American households earned less on
average than asian-american household
but she is one of the put-upon groups
why because intersectional Theory really
is a guise for power relations because
the left sees all race-based discussion
as a way to reverse power relationships
they use intersectionality as a club in
order to beat up people who are not of a
minority group and that's what it's
exactly that's why Sarah Zhang still has
a job today I'm sure on the right should
not have a job that you're white should
not have a job
she has Asian and she's on the left
therefore she has a job today at the New
York Times which tells you a fair bit
about how awful the New York Times it
actually is which is why I say they
should continue to employ her so we can
mock them for their awfulness on a
routine basis okay meanwhile speaking of
awfulness in the media yesterday Jim
Acosta was doing his job at the White
House which is basically to show up on
camera and and show his bouffant to the
world and Jim Acosta as I've said many
times in the past Jim Acosta CNN's White
House correspondent get you somebody who
loves you like Jim Acosta loves Jim
Acosta that dude loves him some Jim
Acosta I mean if if we could retell the
modern myth of narcissus Jim Acosta
would would be in the starring role so
Jim Acosta is it gets into a Sarah
Huckabee Sanders why because President
Trump has done his routine again where
he calls the press the enemy of the
people now as I have said approximately
1 million two hundred and seventy three
thousand three hundred and twenty-two
times on the show I don't think the
media are the
of the people I think this is a silly
line from the president I think the
media lie of fair bet I think more
importantly the media unconsciously
biased their stories in leftward
directions a fair bet I think that that
is I think you have to double check the
media's work on a routine basis and try
and extricate try and separate the
opinion from the fact in their news
stories I think that's your job as a
consumer of news so I'm fully aware of
media bias I've ripped him up media bias
many times on the air with CNN right I'm
the guy who went on CNN and during the
last Gaza war suggested that if Hamas
could have a news outlet it would look
exactly like CNN I'm not shy about
saying to various hosts on various
networks that their networks are biased
I said this I remember to Martin Bashir
before he lost his job at MSNBC that
MSNBC is a left-wing Network and that
they bias their news that way and so
President Trump isn't wrong about that
when he says enemy of the people
not my favorite term because it does
have certain connotations that are just
not correct okay they're not the enemy
of the people they are just biased
sources for a truth they think they are
purveying when they purport to be
objective in any case Jim Acosta has now
made a pretty solid living off of acting
like he is victimized by the American
people who don't trust him now the
reason we don't trust Jim Acosta is not
because Trump said enemy of the people
this is such a left-wing myth that the
right-wing we actually love the media
until President Trump came around then
Trump came around he said mean stuff
about the media and then we were all
like oh man those guys do suck okay in
in like 2001
I think bernard goldberg wrote a book
called bias about bias in the media it
was a number one New York Times
bestseller because everyone on the right
has hated the media for decades because
the media are wildly biased and always
have been certainly as long as I've been
alive going back even further than that
when you had Walter Cronkite who was a
leftist Inever admiral who was a leftist
as the quote-unquote trusted voices of
the American news media so the media has
been biased for literally generations in
the United States it's not that Trump
made us hate the media it's that we
hated the media and then Trump took
advantage of the fact that we hated the
media that's exactly what happened in
election 2016 how do I know this because
in election 2012 Newt Gingrich jumped to
a presidential lead specifically by
smacking around John Harwood in the
middle of the presidential debate he
said you guys heard the biased media
you're awful and everyone yeah that guy
should be President I really leave it's
not unique to Trump in any case Jim
Acosta
now makes a living going around
pending that history started in the last
15 minutes and that now the right hates
the media and we don't like Jim Acosta
not because Jim Acosta is bad at his job
which he is spoiler alert but also that
we really hate the media because Donald
Trump is a big old meaning so he goes to
the White House and he decides this is
gonna be his Sam Donaldson moment he's
gonna sit there and he's going to grill
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the White House
press secretary over whether the media
are the enemies of the people now before
I show you the clip before I play for
you the clip
remember what Sarah Huckabee Sanders his
job is her job is not to express the
opinions of Sarah Huckabee Sanders and
that is specifically not her opinion
this is why somebody from the White
House once asked me would I be
interested in working for the White
House press office which is hilarious
and my answer was of course no because I
prefer to express my own opinion not the
opinion of the president her job is to
express the president's opinion it is
not her job to express her own opinion
or Jim Acosta's opinion or anybody
else's opinion and if she did that she
would not be doing her job Jim Acosta
suggest to Sarah Huckabee Sanders I need
you Sarah Huckabee Sanders to tell me
that the media are not the enemy of the
people but that's not her job and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders I think locks him
pretty good he has this coming you did
not say in the course of those remarks
that you just made that the press is not
the enemy of the people for the sake of
this this room the people who are in
this room this democracy this country
all the people around the world are
watching what you're saying Sarah and
the White House for the United States of
America the presidency should not refer
to us as the enemy of the people his own
daughter acknowledges that and all I'm
asking you to do Sarah is to acknowledge
that right now and right here I
appreciate your passion I share it
I've addressed this question I've
addressed my personal feelings I'm here
to speak on behalf of the president he's
made his comments clear okay and she's
exactly right that is in fact her job
right her job is not to reflect with Jim
Acosta wants to say all right Sarah
Huckabee Sanders wants to say Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is not an elected
official she works at the pleasure of
the President of the United States
end of story now do I like what Trump
says no again I would bet you money that
if you got Sarah Huckabee Sanders on the
phone off the record right now she would
tell you the same thing I'll bet you
that she doesn't like that line either
but does that matter no because that's
not her job and the whole point and a
custom knows that's not her job and his
whole point here is to somehow shame
Sarah Huckabee Sanders as an individual
human
being if he wants to go out and yell
this question to Trump go and yell at a
Trump you want a grill center Huckabee
Sanders over Trump's perspective do that
but to make Sarah Huckabee Sanders the
enemy here is pretty absurd and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders has another response
that is that is just as good Sarah
Huckabee Sanders she then goes off on
CNN I'm gonna play that for you in just
a second but first let's talk about your
energy level the one constant in life is
change society changes technology
changes health innovations change as
well to stay on the cutting edge of
today's fast-paced business environment
you can't rely on energy drinks and
coffee to get you through the day to
crack the code on human performance
there's a team of top physicians and
they gathered to form a brick house
nutrition they came up with a great
product it's called dawn to dusk dawn to
dusk is today's most advanced formula to
stimulate your heart brain and cells by
providing clean energy and focus for up
to 10 hours with no jitters no afternoon
crash you know one of the salespeople
came in for Brickhouse nutrition to meet
with us when the ad agency president and
he represents the company he came in
let's just say he was hyped up and that
dude had flown all day long he was in he
was a high-energy fellow and that was
because he was taken used in coffee that
day it was because he was using
Brickhouse nutrition dawn-to-dusk will
make you the sharpest guy on the
conference call
it'll keep you awake the brightest mind
in the meeting the envy of the obstacle
check it out right now brick house been
calm and use promo code Shapiro at
checkout you get a 15% discount again
brick house been calm use promo code
Shapiro because come on man
I am a brick house hey brick house benzo
come use promo code Shapiro if you're
listening to this podcast on your phone
and you don't have internet access right
now just text promo code Shapiro to four
one four one one four one four one one
four a text reminder for this promotion
don't forget to use that promo code
Shapiro at checkout and get 15% off
again it is brick house comm is brick
house been calm brick house been calm
and use that promo code Shapiro out to
go check it out okay so Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is Grob by Jim Acosta
who wants who he wants her to admit
right here right now the press are not
the enemy of the people
Sarah tell me again are the press the
enemy of the people know is the Sarah
Huckabee Sanders his job to express her
own opinion no and then Sarah Huckabee
Sanders basically wheels around with a
George Foreman like punch and knocks Jim
Acosta through the wall mentioning the
fact that you know while you talk about
how the press or the victims of the
President of the United States you guys
have been pretty awful to Sarah Huckabee
see
here's Sara Huckabee's Hannah is
explaining repeatedly repeatedly the
media resorts to personal attacks
without any content other than to incite
anger the media has attacked me
personally on a number of occasions
including your own Network said I should
be harassed as a life sentence that I
should be choked ice officials are not
welcomed in their place of worship and
personal information is shared on the
Internet
when I was hosted by the Correspondents
Association of which almost all of you
are members of you brought a comedian up
to attack my appearance and call me a
traitor to my own gender in fact as I
know and as far as I know I'm the first
press secretary in the history of the
United States that's required Secret
Service protection the media continues
to ratchet up the verbal assault against
the president and everyone in this
administration and certainly we have a
role to play but the media has a role to
play for the discourse in this country
as that is 100% true right what she said
there is 197 percent true right it is it
is just as pure as omega-3 omics
official I mean is that pure it is it is
absolutely pure stuff is 100% pure okay
what she says there that the media have
been complicit in the failures of trust
and the ending battle between the media
and President Trump is exactly right and
then so what does your Mecosta do with
this information Jim Acosta who loves
him since Jim Acosta what does he do
with this information or he's been told
you know you guys might want to stop
creating a situation where I need
security by Sarah Huckabee Sanders you
might want to create a situation where
you treat people fairly and then maybe
there won't be so many people who are
willing to treat you unfairly maybe
maybe we all we all ought to go weapons
down so what does Jim Acosta do he goes
on TV and he preens and he goes on CNN
and he preens is we should make bumper
stickers because he's a reporter guys an
objective news reporter this is some
serious journalism in you are seeing
right here from Jim Acosta goes on CNN
we should make bumper stickers we should
rally we should get out there in front
of the White House
journalists unite and then Jim Acosta
reveals the fact that he is just as bad
at inventing chance as he is at
journalism in here he is explaining his
bumper stickers well I think you know
maybe we should make some bumper
stickers make some buttons you know
maybe we should go out on Pennsylvania
Avenue like these folks who chant CNN
sucks and fake news maybe we should go
out all
journalists should go out on
Pennsylvania Avenue and shant we're not
the enemy of the people catch bad camp
it's a bad champ also if you really
think that'll definitely work Jim that
will definitely work we don't trust you
at all so I think what you should really
do and we don't trust you in large part
because of your disparate treatment of
Democrats and Republicans so I think
what you really should do is you should
probably go out in front of the White
House where Republican resides and then
you should chance you're not the enemy
of the people
in opposition to Donald Trump supporters
absolutely will respect you more then
you shouldn't do better in terms of your
journalism you shouldn't actually try to
be more objective you shouldn't try to
worship yourself a little bit less Jim
Acosta instead what you should do is you
should go out there and chants about how
awesome you are
that'll probably fix all the things okay
this is just Jim Acosta catering to his
base now again president from cater
stirs basted the difference is what
their jobs are president Trump is a
politician president Trump says a lot of
things to cater to his base that I don't
agree with and that I find abhorrent in
many cases but he is a politician
catering to a base Jim Acosta job is not
to cater to his base Jim Acosta's job is
to ask questions of administration's
that actually have content his job is
not to be an activist if he wants to be
an activist there are plenty of places
for me to do that if he wants to do
opinion journalism then he should just
say I'm an opinion journalist i ben
shapiro
m and opinion journalist right i covered
the news and i have an opinion and you
all know where I stand I'm not hiding
the ball the reason people don't trust
Jim Acosta is not because he's left-wing
the reason people don't trust your
Mecosta is because he proclaims he is
not left wing while acting exactly like
a correspondent for the daily Coast okay
and then he continues along these lines
he says I'm just I'm so tired of this
I'm who cares whether you're tired of
this Jim Acosta why are you the story
why is Jim a cost of the story I don't
understand doesn't make any sense to me
I'm tired of this honestly Brooke I'm
tired of this or maybe even it's it is
not right it is not fair it is not just
it is on American okay okay like get off
your get off your aaron sorkin West Wing
script now Jim and and why don't you
actually try to do your job it's
unamerican I'm so tired of this yeah I'm
sure you have it rough Jim I'm sure I'm
sure things are real rough for you
coming is a guy who needed six hundred
police officers to protect him when he
wanted just speak at Berkeley
I'm sure it's real rough for you that
the president calls you mean names ooh
again should the president
those mean names no but are we gonna
pretend that this is like the end of the
world that the president says this stuff
I'm not gonna pretend that either
because it just come on come on and
here's the thing the the double standard
is just it's glaring and that's why
people don't trust members of me so
another example there's a BBC host
yesterday who's interviewing Sean Spicer
now Sean Spicer was not a good White
House press secretary and Sean Spicer
always looked like he was dying a little
bit behind his eyes like if you could
look through into Sean Spicer soul every
time he had to get up there and talk
about crowd size and act all angry you
could see that there's a part of Sean
Spicer than wanted to crawl into a hole
and just plot okay but Sean's but that
that said Sean Spicer did the same trap
that Jay Carney did when he was at the
White House which is to live for the
president let's be honest about what the
White House press secretary does the job
of White House press secretary is to lie
for the President of the United States
this has been true as long as I have
been alive basically they're very few
press secretaries you don't do it I
really do think that members of the Bush
administration did it less but Jay
Carney used to get up there every day
and say if you like your doctor you can
keep your doctor knowing full well that
wasn't true Robert Gibbs used to do the
exact same thing I confronted Robert
Gibbs about this in 2012 at the DNC I
remember you know so anyway Sean Spicer
goes on BBC and the BBC correspondent
says you have corrupted our entire
political discourse because it is now
news to members of the BBC apparently
that White House press Secretary's fib
on behalf of the president's whom they
serve right it only applies to Sean
Spicer because it's brand-new the world
started turning yesterday you joked
about it when you presented the Emmy
Awards but it wasn't a joke it was the
start of the most corrosive culture you
played with the truth you led us down a
dangerous path you have corrupted
discourse for the entire world by going
along with these lies solid journalism
in there there there really instead of
just asking a question like Sean Spicer
did you mean it when you said that the
President had the largest inaugural
probably she could pin there are a
thousand ways to connect people to the
wall I do it for a living it's not
difficult there are a thousand ways she
could pin him to the wall on dishonesty
but saying that he corrupted the entire
discourse is so free of all context in
the American political system that is
just absurd this is absurd you're right
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't Bill
Clinton stooping interns in the Oval
Office and lying about it to the public
that corrupted the political discourse
it wasn't that it wasn't Joe Biden going
out there and saying that MIT Romney
wanted to put black people back in
Chains that's in corrupt the political
discourse in any way it wasn't Barack
Obama
lying repeatedly about both immigration
and health care that didn't corrupt the
discourse in any way at all for that
matter
it wasn't JFK dumping eighteen-year-old
interns in the in the White House that's
in corrupt America in any way it didn't
corrupt America in any way when
Watergate happened American politics was
clean up to a point when Trump took
office did you know this breaking news
American politics was awesome clean and
pure as the driven snow until Donald
Trump took office at which point evil
people like Sean Spicer came in and
sullied up the place
he's got mud all over the curtains
you're wondering why we don't trust the
me this is why we don't trust the media
okay now what that said in a second I
want to talk about you know president
Trump's impact on the party because I
don't think it's been entirely good on
these things I think that we can be
honest and still destroy the media I
don't think you have to be dishonest to
destroy the media and I also don't think
that you have to say things that are
over the top in order to destroy the
media at least the media's dishonesty I
don't think that our goal should be to
quote-unquote destroy the media as much
dude should be to Club them back into
covering things objectively or at least
announcing their own political
allegiances we'll get into that in just
one second but first you're gonna have
to go over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe now let me tell you something
bout the subscriptions the subscriptions
allow us to bring you the show the
subscriptions allow us to bring you this
beautiful set the subscriptions allow me
to express my brilliance and witticisms
to you on a daily basis they allow
seniya to have a job they allow Jess to
have a job even though she's never seen
The Godfather or jaws they allow a lot
of people in this office to work that is
why you need to go purchase a
subscription right now and help us out
people I get letters like this all the
time how can we help you out the answer
is you can support us by buying a
subscription it's $9.99 a month and when
you get the $99 a year subscription that
is number one cheaper and number two you
get the leftists here's hot or cold
tumblr the most favored tumblr of all
the humans it is just fantastic so go
check that out right now also when you
subscribe at YouTube or iTunes then you
get our Sundays specials which come out
as you may guess from the name every
Sunday our new one has David Mamet the
the author of the untouchables probably
America's greatest living playwright
you'll remember him from the always be
closing speech because he wrote
Glengarry Glen Ross so we had him on
Sunday and we'll talk about everything
from politics to pop culture it's it's
really entertaining so go check that out
right now please leave us a review if
you subscribe to youtube hit the little
bell so that you make sure that you are
updated every time we post a new video
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk a little bit about
the impact that President Trump has had
on the party so I've talked about why it
is the media get all of this deeply
deeply wrong let's now talk about the
fact that the president's rhetoric
undercuts a lot of the good things that
other Republicans are trying to do I
want to be honest about what I think the
president is doing I think that the
president's actions in many cases this
administration's actions are
extraordinarily good judges regulation
foreign policy I agree with a lot of
what the president has done I do
but the president's rhetoric with regard
to these things undercuts a lot of what
Republicans are trying to do because we
have a really good record to run on as
conservatives the economy is great there
was new wage report out today that is
terrific for the president why that
isn't the top of the news cycle well
because every day is a news is a new
news cycle driven by the president's
Twitter accounts or personal animus so
the latest example of this is that the
RNC the Republican National Committee is
now warning that candidates should stay
away from the Koch brothers she is she
delivered her message via a memo says
some groups who claim to support
conservatives forgo their commitment
when they decided their business
interests are more important than those
of the country or the party this is
unacceptable and then she says she's
upset because the cokes have developed
their own data program rivaling that of
the RNC she says from the beginning the
RNC had concerns about any outside
entity building a data operation to
compete with ours because we knew they
could potentially weaponize that data
against Republicans if their business
interests is interest conflicted with
electing Republicans sadly our concerns
were recently proven true okay that is
not the case this is a slander against
the cokes and that is driven
specifically because Trump doesn't like
to Koch brothers he's mad at them
because they are Pro legal immigration
particularly they are a kind of open
borders libertarian on a lot of these
issues and so Trump is very angry at
them for that and so he's slandering the
cokes the cokes are worth 80 billion
dollars 80 billion with a B okay do you
really think that the reason that they
aren't opposing Heidi Heitkamp in North
Dakota is because they have to protect
their business interests or maybe it's
because they've been lifelong
libertarians who have held these
positions for legitimately decades and
they've funded a wide variety of
projects libertarian projects ranging
from the Cato Institute's to other
foundations on the right and backed a
variety of candidates and then this sort
of RNC sudden animus against the Koch
brothers is really dishonest and the
implication they are doing this for
corrupt sleazy business Reese
is quite absurd and that's just a
reflection of the fact that the
president is angry at the Koch brothers
the Republican Party should not become a
tool of the president's it okay when the
president doesn't like something that
doesn't mean that it's bad
sometimes it just means that the
president is wrong that happens right
that happens from time to time another
example of this is Ivanka yesterday
Ivanka Trump who very often is sort of
the moderate face of the administration
she was asked about the president's
enemy of the people talk and here's what
if Annika Trump had to say sorry no I do
not are you looking for me to elaborate
and no I don't I have some sensitivity
around why people have concerns and and
gripe especially when they're sort of
feel targeted but no I do not feel that
the media is the enemy of the people
okay so that is an actually mature
approach to the subject of the press and
president from immediately responded by
attempting to basically take that
comment from Ivanka Trump and turn it
into yeah she actually thinks that the
press of the people so here's what from
tweeted out now you tweet out they asked
my daughter Ivanka whether or not the
media is the enemy of the people
she correctly said no it is the fake
news which is a large percentage of the
media that is the enemy of the people
okay alright so you know is this is this
good stuff is this good for the future
of conservatism no this is not good for
the future of conservatism we should all
be angry when the media bias their case
we should all be angry when they are not
objective but the president's can a
blunderbuss language when it comes to
the media is not useful and the fact
that he's trying to cajole Ivanka Trump
into know she really does believe that
the fake news are the enemy of the
people
see in order to understand why this
tweet is so funny you have to understand
that Trump thinks that virtually all
media that are against him are fake news
so Ivanka Trump says if you ask to Valco
Trump do you think the fake news is fake
news should say no I think that there's
news that is biased I think that like
I've met with Vanka Trump okay I know
Ivanka Trump I do not think that Ivanka
Trump is somebody who is sitting around
going fake news all day like and she's
been targeted by the way much more
unfairly than President Trump you want
to talk about people who have been
absolutely badgered by the media for no
reason whatsoever Ivanka Trump is at the
top of that list right Ivanka Trump got
for me by the media for having the gall
to take an Instagram photo with her own
children in the middle of the
immigration debates and then it became
she's out of touch she's cruel
how dare she be with her kids when other
parents are separated from their kids
Ivanka by the way opposed that
separation policy so it's you know she
has more reason at least every reason
that President Trump has to be angry
with the media when President Trump he
does differ from Ivanka on this topic
but the idea that we're supposed to
follow Trump down every rabbit hole I
just I find it unconvincing unconvincing
at best specifically because it's
distracting from the mission which is to
get things done right Trump says he
wants to get things done okay fine so
get things done now Rudy Giuliani was
asked about 2018 and here was his take
on what 2018 election is going to be
about he's framing this midterm election
in do-or-die terms for the Trump White
House but this election is gonna be
about it they teach you in an occasion
okay so if you really think that's gonna
get people out to the polls
if you think that 2018 should be a
referendum on whether to impeach
President Trump or not you're missing
the fact that what it really should be
is referendum on President Trump's
record it should be a referendum on the
fact that the economy is awesome it
should be a referendum on the fact that
Iran has now been contained in a more
superior way than it was when Obama was
letting them out of the box to destroy
the Middle East it should be a
referendum on President Trump's
regulatory policy it should be a
referendum on all of the areas where the
Trump administration has done well and
the areas where they've done poorly
instead by focusing in on Trump and
making Trump the center of the political
universe what you have done is turned
Republican politics into a black hole of
suck in which anything Trump does that
is bad allows the media to ramp things
up to 11 and it's not going to be good
for Republicans come the election of
2018 we should always be arguing
principles issues and the stuff that
works and yes that includes fighting the
cultural battles that matter but it
doesn't include the the president's
personal animus for the Koch brothers or
his sudden enjoyment of the phrase enemy
of the people okay in just a second
let's do some mail bet you know let's do
some mailbag so it's a Friday you sent
in your letters and now we get to answer
them Jason says hey Ben how do you stay
grounded after becoming famous and
having lots of public attention well I
mean usually I go to my yacht and then I
and then I smoke as many expensive
cigars as I can
lighting $100 bills on fire and then I
cut a music video with jay-z
that's usually how I stay grounded after
work
and in reality I have two kids under
five they run around and they bother
people and they're wonderful and I have
a wife and I have things I need to do at
home and I have a religious obligation
that I fulfill as much as I can every
day and so I don't find it particularly
hard to stay grounded because life
grounds you if you are willing to let it
but you have to you have to be willing
to let it ground you Jacob says hi Ben
with regard your stance on pre-existing
conditions how are people like me having
had a disability since my mom was in a
car accident at five months pregnant
with me afford necessary medical
equipment thanks Jake well my take is
that this is where private charity
really should play a significant role I
mean if you were in my Jewish community
when in my community I really believe in
churches and synagogues and and
community support systems if there are
people in my community who have a
problem typically they go to the rabbi
of the community the rabbi that makes an
appeal to the people of the show and
then everybody sort of pitches in to
help out right the American people are
extraordinarily generous but suggesting
that insurance companies should not be
insurance companies is silly it's not an
insurance company if they are covering
something that has already happened an
insurance policy has taken a guy out do
this just definitional an insurance
policy is taken out against something
that could happen in the future but has
not yet happened you can't burn down
your house and then buy a fire insurance
policy that's not the way it works
because then you're paying in five bucks
for a five million dollar payout yeah
you can't do that you bankrupt the
insurance company that's not insurance
that said the best way health insurance
should actually run seriously is that
people should be purchasing health
insurance on their own right we should
end the employer based health insurance
system your mom should have been able to
not have to have her health insurance
linked to her company she should have
been paying for her health insurance as
she went along you should be part of a
group health insurance program that is
formed with your religious community
there are group coops that are exactly
like this and that's the way that we
should fix the system not with
suggesting insurance companies ought to
not be insurance companies why it says
hey Ben do you like ragtime music ends
you consider it part of the classical
genre so I love ragtime music I think
ragtime music is a lot of fun and it is
it is sort of a crossover between jazz
it's very early jazz basically because
all syncopated rhythm and in classical
music it's terrific I love ragtime which
is one of the reasons I love the movie
The Sting because the entire the entire
score is Scott Joplin which actually
doesn't make a whole hell of a lot of
sense because it takes place in the
1930s and ragtime is really from the
1910s and 1920s but it works in context
rachel says hello Ben after they
finished this current Star Wars trilogy
do you think Disney will keep making
more Star Wars movies do you think some
Old Republic movies would be better or
something sometime after these if I wore
Disney okay so here's what they will do
what they will do is they will launch a
whole series of movies with Rey and Finn
and Poe and all the characters you've
come to know and be lukewarm about but
you what should they do what they really
should do is they should pretend none of
this ever happened they should pretend
the prequels didn't happen they should
pretend the sequels didn't happen they
should recast Han they should recast
Luke they should recast Leia and they
should pick up right where Return of the
Jedi left off that's what they actually
should do because those are the
characters that you like and they've
already shown that they can recast Han
like Alden Ehrenreich did I thought a
creditable job is Han Solo in the way
too solo movie which I actually enjoyed
I think that what they should have done
is just picked up afterward they
shouldn't do prequels for characters
that they the problem with solo the
reason it didn't do well is because
spoiler alert in in force awakens they
kill Han Solo in the worst stupidest
possible way thereby destroying my
childhood and make him a divorce loser
dad murdered by his son okay it's a
terrible terrible way for Han Solo to go
then they decide you know what let's
make a prequel about that guy well why
would I want to watch a prequel about a
guy whose end I already know that's
ridiculous and silly it doesn't make any
sense and what they should do is they
should just KITT the only good really
the only good movies in the Star Wars
Canon are road one which has very little
to do with anything outside of the
original trilogy and and makes very
slight reference to some of the prequels
and they should so keep your old one
keep the original three movies dumb if
you want to keep selling well fine I
guess and dump everything else
pretend force awakens never happened but
certainly pretend last Jedi never
happened and take Kathleen Kennedy's
resume and burn it on a funeral pyre
okay Chelsea says dear Benjamin what
does a typical day look like for you
religiously as an Orthodox Jew but
rituals traditions do you have to do how
strict is your diet also with your day
so full with work and adhering to the
tenants of your religion how do you find
time to control the weather is there an
app on your phone or is there like an
antenna thing under the funny hat thanks
for all you do to teach actual
conservative values well as far as
controlling the weather goes it really
doesn't take a whole hell of a lot of
effort I mean you're talking to a dude
who literally sat here and destroyed
half the MCU okay I didn't do anything i
sat here and half the MCU was gone okay
so it controlling the weather is really
not a problem for me it's really not
that big a deal
but I what's my schedule you know I get
up in the morning I pray in the
afternoon I pray in the evening my pray
Jews pray three times a day I wish I had
more of an opportunity to to pray with
what you call a minyan which is a group
of ten people what you're supposed to do
you're picking the right day to do this
we have a rabbi visiting the studio so
I'm going to act a lot more religious
than I actually am in my daily life but
I keep full kosher
which means I'll only two kosher
restaurants or I'll only eat food that
is made according to particular
standards and I can give you the whole
spiel on what kashrut is and why it
exists and what the restrictions are and
then I keep Sabbath which means that
from Friday night to Saturday night -
one hour past sunset on Saturday night I
don't use any electric devices so I'm
not on my phone I'm not tweeting I'm not
using my computer somebody asked earlier
how do I keep grounded one of the ways
you keep ground is you turn off your
phone you turn off your computer and you
have Shabbat right so the Sabbath really
does keep you grounded in a pretty
significant way Joe says hey Ben my best
friend was hit by a drunk driver in 2015
and has suffered serious injuries that
almost ended his life you will forever
have physical limitations the person who
hit him was on bar cameras drinking
excessive amounts of alcohol and blew a
point one seven an hour after the
incident occurred my question is what
are your views on dram shop rules laws
that make bars liable for over-serving
should bars be held responsible for
over-serving people who are obviously
intoxicated loved the show and thanks so
I do have a problem with dram shop rules
I think the idea of holding a bar
responsible for a patron voluntarily
intoxicating themself beyond the legal
limit I think it's it sets a dangerous
precedent it seems to me that that
verges on making gun shops liable for
somebody coming in buying a gun and then
shooting somebody I'm not a big fan of
dram shop rules the argument against
just to present the counter-argument is
that once somebody is intoxicated they
no longer have the power to make
independent judgments and so you are
basically preying on them by selling
them alcohol but in just the same way
that our law suggests that you are
responsible for first-degree murder if
you get in the car drunk and hit
somebody you are responsible for getting
drunk if you decide to get drunk so I'm
not a big fan of holding the bartender
liable for any of that I'm a bigger fan
of holding the responsible individual
holding responsible the individual who
is who's actually participating in the
behavior Blake says dear Ben is a
California myself why do you still live
in the state have you considered moving
to a state County etcetera that share
similar values with half the taxes and
double as Hannity yeah
any Californian who has a business or
who operates in the state has thought
about moving
there there are a couple reasons why I
stay and obviously the weather which I
control second of all and then the
second of all I the as an Orthodox Jew I
have to be in a place that has a
significant number of kosher restaurants
and more importantly Jewish schools for
my kids
and so that limits the number of places
I can live like I would love to be able
to go and like buy a huge state in
Montana or something and create my own
country that would be great
but there are no kosher shops in Montana
I'd have to learn how to slaughter
cattle and that's really not on my
agenda so that means that they're really
only there the truth is the the Orthodox
Jewish community is centralized in a few
places around the United States to New
York it's in Dallas it's in Chicago it's
in La La's the second biggest Jewish
population in the United States after
New York and so it limits the sort of
places I can live and LA is better in
New York I mean come on come on
I mean la is just way better than New
York and every possible I first of all
is not filled with New Yorkers so
there's that
okay let's see drew says dear Ben well
though I'm not a big fan of his Russo
said something to the effect in order
for people to properly vote in a
democracy they must be properly educated
therefore would be the responsibility of
the government to educate the population
even Thomas Jefferson said something to
this effect my question is now that the
government has taken on the
responsibility of Education wouldn't it
be proper for the people to take a test
in order to vote despite the negative
historical implications that poll tests
have in this country I feel this would
be a good solution to politicians
preying on the ignorant and I'm torn on
this question obviously I wish that the
American public were more educated but I
think that you'd have to determine what
exactly is the standard for that for
those polls right I mean would have to
be knowledge of current events I'm not
sure why it should should have to be
knowledge of current events what if you
spend your days studying Plato Aristotle
and Cicero it seems to me you know
enough about politics at that point to
vote then you just never read newspapers
I don't really see why shouldnt be able
to vote how do you test for that sort of
stuff is it a literacy test well you
know your own interests without a
literacy test so well I think the idea
is is correct that we should have more
populous popular literally educated
group of people voting I'm not sure how
you decide what elements go into a poll
test that make you eligible to vote in
the first place that that don't bias the
voting population I think it'd be it
would be difficult to figure that out
Daniel says hey Ben could you explain
your reason for abolishing the IRS in
further detail thanks shabbat shalom
well really abolishing the IRS is just a
byproduct of abolishing the income tax I
think the income tax is an awful awful
institution the sixteenth amendment
should be
repealed as soon as humanly possible
it's garbage and we should we should go
back to sales taxes and state taxes and
the nice thing that a sales tax you
don't need the IRS to enforce it and the
nice thing about a sales tax is people
just send in the money as a percentage
of the sales they rack up and then you
don't need the IRS auditing people you
still need some agency doing it maybe
you keep the IRS and you call it the IRS
but you cut it down to about five guys
all right as opposed to they don't have
to dig through every receipt that you
took a deduction on and now they have to
go through and they have to determine
what your income was and are you lying
about it like it's just it's it's a mess
okay sorry final question here Thomas
says hello mr. Shapiro my daughter
recently turned seven and has expressed
an interest in learning to play violin
knowing that you are masterful violinist
do you have any advice for beginners and
for parents with very little experience
in music well if you're talking about
higher ed could you learn violin the
Suzuki method really is good for for
learning at the very beginning I studied
Suzuki method for probably let's see
from time I was five till the time I was
maybe 11 so maybe six or seven years and
and it is a great way to learn to play
violin and then you find more advanced
teachers as your kid gets older you do
have to make your kids practice yeah
this is one of the questions that you
see with parents with it my kid doesn't
want to practice and I don't want to
make my kid practice okay then your kid
won't be good really I mean that's
that's that's the answer right I
practiced at the beginning we have maybe
10 15 minutes a day it got to the point
where when I was really good I was
practicing you know maybe 3 hours a day
or more when I was really first-rate you
know my daughter is learning to play now
she's four and a half and it's difficult
to get her to sit still long enough to
practice but you make her do it right I
mean and yet when I say to her when she
does wanna practice okay well then we're
not gonna pay for your lessons right if
you don't want to practice then we're
not going to actually expend money to go
take you to a lesson you have to if you
wanna have your lessons if you want to
learn then you have to look then you got
to sit here and you have to learn and
she's learning to play right she's
already she's already doing this at four
and a half so there is an enforcement
mechanism you can't let your kid get
that we have this whole idea well if the
kids not enjoying it the kid shouldn't
do it then your kid will suck at
everything but your kid doesn't enjoy
school just note to mom and dad your kid
doesn't enjoy school you make them go
anyway because if you think it's
important for you to learn a musical
instrument be good at it do it that way
also I'm not a fan of the my kid plays
11 instruments then your kids terrible
at all of them in all likelihood right
in reality your kids really only gonna
be good at one instrument maybe two if
your kid is extraordinarily talented
don't do this oh but but he plays just a
little bit of Trump
no he doesn't he blasts a horrible sound
out of a trumpet and then he goes and
makes a horrible sound on the violin he
doesn't play trumpet or violin okay
let's do some things I like and then
some things that I hate and then we'll
get out of here for the weekend okay so
things I like speaking of classical
musicians and classical training
I took my four and a half year old
daughter to the Hollywood Bowl the other
night it is a blast if you've never been
to the Hollywood Bowl one of the reasons
to live in what LA is to go to the
Hollywood Bowl because it is just it's
this beautiful outdoor venue it was like
75 degrees that night with the with the
breeze and you're watching great
musicians play great music in the middle
of basically a wooded area of Los
Angeles it's just fantastic so my
daughter I was really proud of her she
sat through an hour-and-a-half concert
of Grieg so she sat through the peer
gynt suite and she also sat through the
Greek piano concerto so good for her I
mean she's my daughter's awesome she's
she's really bright and awesome she's I
like her in any case I don't like you
but I like her in any case she's so she
she sat through the pianist is guy named
George Lee and he is just tremendous I
guess they played the Greek piano
concerto very good performance and then
he played an encore and the encore that
he played was a a riff on bezees Carmen
bye that was written by Vladimir
Horowitz one of the great pianists of
the 20th century and here is a recording
of him doing this he's just terrific if
you want you can check out his
recordings I think I want a silver at
the at the international Tchaikovsky
Competition he's in crowd my dad's a
professional pianist and my dad was
sitting next to me I was sitting here my
wife was sitting here my daughter was
sitting here my dad was sitting on the
other side when my dad was just his jaw
hit the floor he saw this guy play he's
only 23 I think so here he is playing
playing some Bizet
[Music]
as 30 points have a really difficult
so people always ask me why I'm gonna
lead us to bat music because I like
skill so the same reason I'm gonna lead
us about sports right when I watched
basketball I want to watch the NBA when
I watch baseball I want to watch the MLB
I want to watch college baseball I don't
want to watch college basketball I want
sure the best ok this is why when people
say you know you're very hard on rap
right if you were able to pick up a
microphone one day and be good at
something it didn't require a lot of
skill really seriously if you if you
have to this guy train I promise you
who's practicing 8 hours a day from the
time this kid was probably eight years
old okay if that's why he's really good
okay and you have to admire people who
actually spend time perfecting a skill
this holds trim politics also I get a
lot of questions from people how do I
get into politics the answer is you read
and you read and you read and then you
write and then you write and then you
write and then you do this for lots of
years and then you eventually get good
at things right this is actually how you
get good at things you spend an awful
lot of time prepping things if there's
anything you do but whether it's popular
whether it's not popular where it was oh
yeah I picked up a guitar one day and in
three months I was good enough that I
could cut CDs and now I'm selling a
million records okay that means that
you're popular it doesn't mean that
you've done anything that I think is
extraordinarily worthy of praise this is
a general rule as a general rule I think
that you ought to have to put in an
enormous amount of time to demonstrate
this kind of skill I'm not gonna pretend
that I think that this guy and Taylor
Swift are on the same level
they ain't sorry son yeah they're not
okay like Taylor Swift plays a few
chords on guitar and then she writes
wordy lyrics that are somewhat charming
sometimes that says much as you're gonna
get out of me and then and if you're
going to compare that or you can come
here rap where somebody cannot even
rhyme okay half half the rap I've
listened to is people doing near rhymes
which is the easiest garbage in the
world like my Matt my daughter can do it
she's four and a half that's not to say
that those people are not good at what
they do it's to say that what they do
does not require a ton of skill there
are lots of things in life where he can
be good at them without a ton of work
okay playing piano is not one of them
playing violin is not one of them
playing this kind of stuff is not one of
them and if you're gonna ask me who I
admire more George Lee who will sell
maybe 1/100 the CDs that any of these
other artists I've mentioned ever will
so I admire him more or do I admire
Taylor Swift more there is no question
there's just no question okay perfect a
skill get good at it
it requires dedication and frankly stuff
that comes hard is better for you as a
general was as a human being then stuff
that comes really easily okay time for a
couple of things that I hate
okay so I've never heard of this queuing
on stuff so I've just I've just been
informed of this in the last week the
reason I was informed of it is because
somebody tweeted something at me on a
topic I didn't really know and they had
a blue checkmark and so like an idiot I
sort of retweeted it and then somebody
emailed me in there like do you believe
- and I'm like I don't know the hell
queue and on is and that looked at was
like oh I shouldn't retweet of that so I
unroot we did it and queue and on I
guess is this conspiracy theory about
the deep state and the and the workings
of a military government and it's all
this weird garbage that's weird garbage
conspiracy theory I'm not gonna pretend
to understand it because I haven't spent
more than five minutes looking at it
because it makes no sense at all I
basically suggest that there's a
conspiracy led by President Trump where
he leads the executive branch in these
conspiratorial designs which makes no
sense since he's actually the head of
the executive branch isn't neither a
military conspiracy inside the exact
he's the head of it and in any case
Chris Cuomo who is a block of wood Chris
Cuomo on CNN he is looking for a way to
tie president Trump takuan on to say the
president Trump his conspiracy theorist
know why you have to stretch to get here
is beyond me
President Trump has in the past tweeted
about how vaccines are a scam which is
silly he's tweeted in the past about
Barack Obama I'm a big deal out of this
was born in Kenya right like if you want
to show that President Trump is fond of
conspiracy theories it's actually not
hard at all
but instead Chris Cuomo in his attempt
to pegged President Trump with the qyn
on nonsense goes even further and
creates his own weird conspiracy theory
so watch because this is hysterically
funny hewn on cue anonymous internet
conspiracy collective you see them at
Trump rallies they have their Seth rich
signs we are Q that's them Q is the 17th
letter in the alphabet not that that
helps make any sense of its significance
to them and they see Trump tweeting
something like this seventeen angry
Democrats they take value in the number
seventeen a potential sign I hope he
didn't use that number for them he
hasn't always used the number seventeen
I don't see that as being intentional
but who knows these days who knows these
days journalism Inc
excellent journalism Inge block of wood
Chris Cuomo excellent excellent job
I see why we trust you it's okay
this is a quote from an outlet you may
have heard of called CNN okay
February 23 2018 special accounts of
robert muller assembled the team of at
least 17 lawyers for his investigation
of Russian interference in the 2016
election Wow
I can't believe that CNN is appealing to
the qa9 group like that I can't believe
that they are actually just shouting out
17 to get those qa9 people all revved up
CNN are they part of the conspiracy -
hmm and this is so stupid
everything is stupid that's gonna be our
next t-shirt at the Shapiro store
everything is stupid you know - Ben
Shapiro like that that's my quote
that'll sell a million copies because
everyone agrees with that proposition
everything is stupid okay other things
that I hate so Don jr. did a premiere
for Dinesh D'Souza's new film Dinesh has
a new film out I can fairly say that I
think that the at least the marketing
campaign for the new film is not my cup
of tea
comparing President Trump to to
President Lincoln the trailer for the
new film basically suggests that
President Lincoln was shot by horrible
Democrats who are attempting to
re-establish slavery and now President
Trump faces a similar challenge no no
I'm sorry
nope nope 600,000 Americans died while
Lincoln was president because they were
killing each other hey that that nope
nope sorry no no I mean and I'm first to
say I think the media have targeted
President Trump I think that the
Democratic Party has become incredibly
radical I disagree with a lot of the
things they say no okay any poster that
mashes up Trump's face with Lincoln's
face automatic no okay so but Donald
Trump jr. was at the premier and he
proceeded to so one of the things Dinesh
has talked about is sort of a premise
that he took from Jonah Goldberg it's
liberal fascism about how the Nazis were
actually left-wing in a lot of ways now
to understand the Nazis what you have to
understand is that European politics is
not the same as American politics there
is no such thing as a European
conservative party classical liberalism
which is the motivating factor behind
American conservatism the idea of small
government God guaranteed rights that
are that are guaranteed and protected by
a limited government that is established
only to protect those rights that is an
American idea it is not a European idea
right John Locke talked about but it was
really adopted by the American founders
and adopted nowhere else when you talk
about European right-wing parties while
you're talking about our parties
still embraced nationalized healthcare
that still embraced full-on social
safety nets that really still embrace
all sorts of lefty programs in a variety
of ways but just happened to be more
nationalist on issues like immigration
and culture are there more culturally
assimilationist as opposed to
multicultural that's sort of the great
distinguishing factor and on occasion
they might be in favor of slightly more
austerity measures but there's no such
thing as a right-wing party in Europe
the same way that conservatives are
right-wing in the United States it just
doesn't exist in Europe and in anywhere
near the same way so when you look at
the Nazi Party the Nazi Party was
right-wing as compared with the
Communist Party in Germany so when the
Left says the Nazis were right-wing they
are correct in the sense that they were
the right wing of European politics but
the Nazis bear no resemblance to the
American conservative movement as in
none okay there's no crossover
whatsoever so Jonah pointed this out let
me pointed out that the Nazis were
called National Socialists believed in
big government nationalized health care
corporate control from the top of
Industry right that all these things are
left-wing propositions which is true
dinesh took that further and he
basically said well the Nazis are the
Democrats all right the Nazis in the
Democratic Party share a lot of common
thoughts now the problem that I have
with this is the way that we treat Nazi
in public discourse because the reality
is the reason that everybody hates the
Nazis is because World War Two in the
Holocaust
up until World War Two in the Holocaust
the reality is that the vast majority of
the West was kind of okay with the Nazis
which demonstrates how much of the West
is sick together then if you look at the
Nazis actual agenda there are a lot of
people today if you just remove the word
Nazi at the top who would look at the
agenda that they talk about
internationalized health care more
spending on on veterans more of the
public education more restrictions on
industry tariffs on what they called
autarky the idea we should produce all
product in-house inside Germany there
are a lot of people on both sides of the
aisle who'd probably agree with some of
those propositions because it was a
political party that also happened to be
motivated by a deep-rooted evil and it's
a fascist he was a fascist tyranny that
suggested a one-party state was the best
okay to try and link that to today's
Democratic Party I think we need to be
careful about the Nazi comparison so
unless you are just like what people do
is they say Democratic party platform
like the Nazi platform and Nazis went
and killed six million Jews okay that's
that's intellectually dishonest
well you couldn't say it's just this
this is a bad agenda hey this is Jenna's
bad it's failed everywhere it's tried it
tomorrow lots of parties have embraced
it from right to left and it's not good
in Europe instead
from jr. basically goes to the bumper
sticker version of this which is the
Democratic party platform is the Nazi
platform when you look at the actual
history of how these things evolved and
when you actually look at that platform
versus the platform of the modern Left
you say wait a minute those two are
really heavily aligned and frankly
contrary to the right you see the non-si
platform in the early 1930s and what was
actually put out there as it and you
look at it compared to like the TNC
platform of today you're saying man
those things are awfully similar okay
he's he's not totally wrong that they're
elements of the Democratic Party
platform that are very similar to the
the elements of the deck of the Nazi
Party platform but the reason we hate
the Nazis is not really because of that
platform the reason we hate the Nazis
because the Holocaust in World War 2 so
it's intellectually dishonest to sort of
make that switch and and I want to point
that out because there's no reason for
the intellectual dishonesty you can just
make arguments about how the policy is
bad without hitting it with the swastika
right the policy happens to be bad
nationalized health care has been tried
in a bunch of different places in a
variety of different ways it is bad
because it is bad in the places in which
it is bad it's not bad because you
linked the swastika to it I just don't I
don't appreciate that particular linkage
okay so we'll be back here on Monday and
we'll have much more for you then so
have a great weekend rest up because
we're gonna be back at this on Monday
and I expect you to be in tip-top form
I'll see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018